exactly
is
so
[Music]
thanks
good afternoon welcome to the table what
a beautiful day outside and a beautiful
time to be here with you guys
um
what a blessing to be sitting here in a
safe place in a community with people
who love you
with all that's going on in the world we
are real this is a gift and i'm so
thankful to be sharing that with all of
you right now whether you're online or
here in person or you're listening to
this three days later so thankful
um the table in and of itself is a gift
and there are five pillars that it is
built upon that are just
precious to me as an individual i love
these words and that is
i'm going to say them and i just want
you guys to pause and really breathe in
these words and know that these are
little gifts that are packaged just for
you
and they're just great words
thoughtfulness
inclusivity
being a collective
vulnerability
and communal
those words are some of my absolute
favorite words and i think they web
together
the most comfortable safe beautiful cozy
blanket that you could ever imagine and
that blanket is for your heart to wrap
around you or your wounds wherever you
are and to wrap around anyone that you
invite into this space
and it's
god's word it's jesus's love it's who we
should be and who we strive to be and
it's for you
today in this moment through the songs
that are going to be played through the
message through the story that is going
to be shared every little detail
from someone saying hello to you and
then saying goodbye to you has been
thoughtfully created for this experience
here today to worship jesus and to make
you feel those five attributes that are
truly for you
speaking of this beautiful community
that i love so much next sunday
following the service at 6 15 we're
going to have our state of the table
which is a really cool name and i wish
we had shirts that we wore on that day
so
we can do that
we're going to get together and talk
about um just family business so if you
call the table home please come to that
if you're more interested in seeing what
we're about please come to that we'll be
talking about leadership transitions
financial
things of the church money's not my
thing but that's a very important part
so we'll talk about that
and if you have any questions that is a
great time to ask them
april 17th is easter sunday we will not
be meeting here
we will be meeting at blue heron event
center which is just down the street
from here at 10 30 in the morning we'll
have an easter egg hunt for the kids
it's going to be a really special
service and we'd love for you to be
there and bring a friend or two or 30
but let us know if you're bringing 30
because we'll need more easter eggs
so as we transition into this time of
worship i'm just gonna say a prayer and
really take a deep breath
and enter into this space that was
curated just for you
god thank you so much
for a safe place to be
to seek you to know you to feel you and
god i pray that we would feel that in
spades tonight
god we pray for our brothers and sisters
all over the world who
are not feeling that right now
would you draw near would you reign
peace over them would you change the
narrative with your your truth with your
love
that people would be drawn to peace and
not war
god
i just pray over every heart in this
room whether it's holding
big gaping wounds or small little
bruises that tonight your love your
truth your goodness would wrap that
blanket
of of medicine of love of jesus around
those parts of us
and
would accelerate healing and that we
would know that while we're in this
space it is one truly made for us
because of you
and that we can walk out of these doors
knowing you more seeking you more loving
others more
and make a ripple effect of this world
looking more and more like you help us
guide us
beckon us
in your son's sweet name amen
amen thanks kelly
you guys um i just invite you all to
stand with us we're gonna caitlin's
gonna get us started
um and if you haven't heard this song
before it's kind of one of those table
classics so just join in clap along
sing out hallelujah with us whatever it
is that makes you feel
um a part of this experience because you
most certainly are all right
[Music]
your love
sing in your name
[Music]
to your desired
is
[Music]
like blazing wildfires
may this
stretch across the skies
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah sing hallelujah
[Music]
to your
stretch design the skies
[Music]
is
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah all right
when darkness tries to roll over my
bones
when sorrow comes to steal the joy out
brokenness and pain is all i
[Music]
my know
doesn't stand a chance when i stand in
your love my fear doesn't stand a chance
when i stand in your love my fear it
doesn't stand a
chance in your love
[Music]
i'm is afraid to leave my past behind
i won't be shaking
my feet
[Music]
my fear doesn't stand a chance when i
stand
[Music]
there's power
in your
[Music]
there's resurrection
when i stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when i stand in
your love my fear doesn't stand a chance
when i stand in your love
does it stand a chance
[Music]
god we invite you into
this space with us
we trust you with our fears
we trust you with our feelings
but above all that god we just invite
your truth
we invite your word
and the message of your gospel
would you guys join me in the prayer of
the people and um if you're online with
us we invite you also to leave a comment
or
whatever you're carrying on your heart
a situation maybe leave that in there
and we will also
share those as we can with the room
please read this along with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community
and all of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you
for the poor and the pressed for the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations up to you
breakthrough
kirsten and brandon
sue
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
thank you guys
as we go into the next song
i just invite you to
soak in these lyrics
it talks about a simple gospel and as
we're in the middle of the lent season
i'm going through the book of john and
if i'm completely honest there are so
many pieces where i'm like going back to
my journal and being like i don't get it
like you know there's just parts of the
bible that are not
as clear as i wish they were or as easy
to interpret as i wish it was or
you know you name it it's just
and and it might just be me but it's
just sometimes it doesn't feel as simple
as i want it to be
but if i come back
to what i know to be true about jesus
and the life that he lived
the simplicity
of someone who would lay down their life
for others the simplicity of redemption
and forgiveness
the simplicity of truth
i can ground myself in that and all of
the questions and
struggles sometimes
can be set to the side for a moment and
i can just feel like
god's nearness and his closeness is
enough to carry me through
i can feel like his strength
and his peace
and his goodness is there with me
and there's room for my questions
and sometimes they don't have to be
answered you know
we dwell on the things that we know
and i pray god right now
that the things that we know about you
would resonate in us as we sing these
words
would you meet us in this space
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
i wanna know you
[Music]
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
[Music]
i wanna know you know
i wanna know
[Music]
i wanna
wanna know
[Music]
i used to think
that i could
[Music]
know box
lord
i used to think
that i could box you in
but i'm laying down
i wanna know
[Music]
lord i've been told
to be ashamed
i don't measure up
lord i've been told
i'm not good enough
[Music]
you say no amount of untruths
can
separate us
[Music]
oh you found me jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
i reach out and you
you find me
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
[Music]
i will rejoice
in a sinful gospel
in you lord
i will rejoice
in a simple gospel
will rejoice
[Music]
[Applause]
do i see
to you
[Music]
is
god thank you for who you are
thank you god that you're a rock that we
can stand on
when all else is sinking stand
you are our rock
we invite you into this space god keep
speaking to us
would we find you
in the smiles around us
in the warmth of our love
and the words that brett shares
god would we hear that message
of forgiveness of grace
of goodness
you're welcome here jesus
we love you
amen
thanks guys y'all can be seated and
brett's going to come and give his
message to us if you want to turn and
welcome the people around you make them
feel at home that'd be awesome
all right good evening
grace and peace
how are you all doing
yeah
good good good
well um it's a joy it's a joy to be with
all of you
and um i also want to welcome uh just
like kelly did those joining us online
and anyone who is new um or if just your
first time
in a long time
it's uh really really good to be with
you
so we are um
in a series right now titled lent at the
table uh it is of course the season of
lent in the christian calendar um and
lin is basically uh just a season of of
spiritual preparation um as we approach
good friday the day of the cross and and
then after that easter so it's 40 days
not including sundays uh kind of leading
into that
so um
you know this will be a lot in the
gospels and specifically the gospel of
luke um in this uh this series since
that's kind of the uh the prescribed
readings i'm jumping on the united
methodist church um their their calendar
so i just i just preach on whatever
that is whatever it says
and i've found that it's actually it's a
good discipline like we've talked about
in um in the past we'll do kind of
different types of series we'll do like
topical series on you know just things
that feel relevant or timely or needed
um other times we'll go through like a
book of the bible um like we've been
doing with first peter which we'll come
back to at some point and and then other
times we just jump on the church
calendar and join in i like doing that
because it's it's a cool way of joining
in with the broader church you know it's
good to remember it's not like just
about us
you know or our little community and we
kind of have our own way you know it's
it's it's good i think to remember like
hey we are part of the church universal
and uh so at any rate that's that's kind
of what we're doing in this series so
the uh the title of my message tonight
is uh fox and hen
not the hound
uh
fox and then
it was the weirdest timing though this
week i'd go in the living room and uh
my nephew he's watching fox and the
hound and i was like my gosh i haven't
seen this in like 20 years and on this
very sunday there it is like i don't
know the universe is a strange place
um so fox in the hen
and our primary text is going to be luke
chapter 13 verses 31 through 34. um
usually i'll just kind of like read the
whole thing and then we'll kind of go
into it but i'm going to we're going to
kind of take it just verse by verse and
kind of unpack it as we go as the as the
story unfolds so to speak so let's start
with verse 31 here
uh at that time
some pharisees came to jesus and said to
him leave this place and go somewhere
else
herod wants to kill you
so
uh it's it's interesting that the
pharisees are saying this to jesus uh if
you have ever read any of the gospels
you know like the pharisees are almost
always the you know antagonists you know
jesus is the protagonist and the hero of
the story then the pharisees are like
you know always kind of trying to trip
him up catch him in his words you know
set some verbal trap or something and so
it's a little strange here we have the
the pharisees you know trying to like
help jesus so you know scholars
speculate like maybe maybe they're being
tricksy maybe somehow they want to
actually get out it's it's a little
strange um
it's possible though that there are just
some pharisees that were inclined to
like or help jesus we know just a few
chapters before this um
jesus's cousin john the baptist has been
executed by herod
so
you know maybe
maybe they are maybe they actually are
genuine maybe they we honestly don't
totally know um
but regardless
jesus has quite the response
uh jesus replied verse 32 go tell that
fox
i will keep on driving out demons
and healing people
today and tomorrow
and on the third day i will reach my
goal
in any case i must press on today and
tomorrow and the next day for surely no
prophet can die outside jerusalem
so all right so two questions i think
naturally come to mind at this point um
number one who is herod
and why does jesus call him a fox so
which by the way i take it not as a
compliment maybe today i don't know if
that's still a compliment like i don't
know
fox it's like handsome i guess i don't
know um but that's not ogn used doesn't
mean in that way but all right let's
talk about herod first so who is this
harrod guy so basically herod was a
puppet king
kind of a ruler of the province
basically when rome conquered
the jewish people in the city of
jerusalem they put their people in place
you know sort of like imagine if
god forbid putin's successful in ukraine
right then
they may even still call it ukraine
you know or at least the city leave the
city with its name and yet he was going
to put his person in charge right um and
that's kind of this situation here it's
sort of like rome conquered and so they
choose someone who i think if i recall
herod was like half jewish
um
so
he's sort of you know he's kind of
trying to walk the line of like oh i'm
for the people and for rome you know so
of course the the
jewish people they weren't fans not fans
of herod he was also known as quite a
brutal ruler
and um quite cunning
which is why actually you know jesus
calls him a fox
um
and you know it's interesting when i
think of like a king though i kind of
think more like lion
you know like why not the lion the tiger
the wolf you know power these are
symbols of power um and i think it's
because you know cr foxes are they're
they're crafty
you know like that's what foxes are
known for like they're predatory just
like lions or wolves or things but foxes
man they're intelligent i think this
makes them a very good kind of animal
analogy or um kind of metaphor for human
beings right because we aren't
necessarily known for like our physical
just prowess at least compared to like
in the animal kingdom you know us
against a great white shark in the water
not gonna be awesome you know for us um
but what sets us apart kind of an animal
kingdom it's those intelligence right so
you got foxes are smart humans are smart
um and not just smart but foxes are sly
humans can be sly and foxes can be i
mean they're predators right and humans
at our worst um we can be quite uh quite
predatory so
um
i i and i think what i said when i say
predatory what i mean is to kind of
stretch that that analogy i'm getting at
the idea that we don't kind of like
foxes they're sneaky i've been watching
um a series on netflix some of you all
have probably seen alone
anyone following
the series alone if not you should it's
amazing just people out in the
wilderness literally alone trying to
make it and of course foxes foxes are
like an issue
and oh those they're smart
they're smart and they're stealing stuff
and they're like but they're always
sneaky you know because foxes aren't the
most powerful they're not bears just
lumbering around like i'll do what i
want out here you know like that's not
foxes they're they gotta be sly and
that's
that's uh i think kind of how we humans
are like we rarely especially at least
as adults this is why we sort of adore
children and they drive us crazy but
they're just kids are just open and
honest about everything you know i mean
just like if they're gonna sin they're
just gonna be like hey here it is you
know
and uh humans you know us adults we're
we're sneaky
you know it's like we're gonna mess
things up or we're going to kind of act
in those you know kind of the worst
parts of us
we're going to probably be you know kind
of sly
about it and um i think it's interesting
how even like we'll often distance
ourselves from politicians you know like
when talking about politicians it's
almost everyone kind of despises just
like oh you can't trust them um which is
always kind of a red flag like whenever
there's a person or a group of persons
that we're kind of distancing ourselves
from with a lot of emotion
usually what is it we kind of see like
the worst parts of us
in them and that's why we're so strong
to like this oh i can't believe those
politicians can you believe those liars
like manipulative conniving
sneaky
and it's like yeah
[Music]
at our worst are aren't we kind of
fox-like
isn't that kind of like aren't we at
least at least more than a touch
of politician in all of us adults you
know um
i yeah i think i think jesus is i think
he's
he's on to something here um there's a
great scene in the dark night
where uh if you've seen it you won't
forget it it's where the joker is
talking to harvey dent
who was a politician and he's there
harvey's now been injured and he's um
he's got like you know half his face
hurt
and he's there in the hospital bed and
the joker's has this little speech um
with him
and uh
what does he say he's like oh that's
right he the joker goes to harvey kind
of leaning over you can see in this
image he's like leaning over and he says
um you know what i am he says i am i'm a
dog chasing cars
i wouldn't know what to do with one if i
caught it and you can see here the
joker's sort of a symbol of like chaos
and anarchy in the whole movie he's
almost inhuman like not human in that
way
um
he says that you know that's me like i'm
just a dog chasing cars just he says i
just do things
uh and he says but the mob
has plans y'all remember this scene
the mob has plans the cops have plans uh
gordon the chief police has he's got
plans
you know what they are harvey says he
says they're schemers
they're schemers trying to control their
little worlds
i'm just trying to show the schemers how
pathetic
their attempts to control things really
are
in that power i mean
now in this moment like well and
actually then he gets personal and he
says well not only it was the schemers
who put you where you are harvey but
then he says and you were a schemer
you had plans
and look where that got you
i mean in this moment what is that
character what's the joker what's he
naming
he's naming humanity's fox-like
ways
he's got us
which is why the joker is different
because he doesn't have plants he's he's
just
chaotic but we're not we're not chaotic
now
um
here's the thing my point tonight isn't
so much just to talk about us though in
our you know
all of our fox-like ways what i really
want to name um
is that while humanity
is fox like
uh god is not
while humanity may be fox-like god is
not
um
in other words god is not violent or
conniving
or manipulative
god is not a schemer
um and another maybe verses in the bible
where god
is named or imaged in those ways for
sure you can certainly find them
but i think what's happening in those
passages is actually it's human beings
projecting
our own fox-like ways onto god
it's us justifying ourselves
but but you see to be christian is not
to just read the bible as a flat text it
is to interpret it in a very specific
way and specifically to understand who
god is in a specific way
it is we we take every every verse every
image of god that's given and we we kind
of interpret it through the life
the teachings
the character
the very revelation
of who god is that we see in the face of
jesus christ
like that's what it means to be a
christian
so humanity may be fox-like um god is
not
and and this is why what you get in this
this next verse is
um
this moment
where jesus
um
well it's honestly it's one of the most
tender beautiful images of god that we
have in the entire bible so remember he
just finished saying um you know go tell
that fox um
i'm gonna keep on healing people i'm
going to keep on
setting people free from the demonic and
i'm going to keep on doing the work that
god's called me to do and then he says
you know because i'm headed towards
jerusalem
um because no prophet can die outside
jerusalem and then as though that
that word jerusalem kind of triggers
jesus memory
all of a sudden he starts lamenting this
is verse 34.
he says o jerusalem jerusalem
you who kill the prophets
and you stone those
sent to you
how often i have longed to gather your
children together
as a hen
gathers her chicks under her wings
and you were not willing
is that a stunning image
this is who jesus reveals god to be
it's a picture it's a very maternal
mother-like image isn't it
this is who god is
you know sometimes when i
read the scriptures i'll imagine it kind
of playing out like a movie i think one
of the more stunning things about this
passage remember he just finished
talking about jerusalem and he even
talks about going there to die
and we know how he's going to die
and when i see this play out i imagine
jesus as he's saying oh jerusalem
jerusalem i've longed i've longed to
gather your children together
as a hen
gathers her chicks under her wings can
you see the image i just imagine him
what's he doing with his hands
can you kind of see it
like oh jerusalem jerusalem i just i've
longed
to just gather you together what's it
what's it a picture of it's like this
it's this picture of
the cross
as he stretches out his arms
wide
on across to die for who for us
for his children
to bring us back into relationship
back into intimacy back into
connectedness
this
is who god is humanity may be fox-like
god is not
now of course what's a little bit tricky
is that depending on
the context in which you were raised
depending on your church context
how you were raised in the culture maybe
even a totally different religious
context who knows um but depending on
those contexts the way we image god
can be quite uh different can honestly
at times be quite fox-like
and and so this becomes somewhat of a
transition a journey
for us to let go of those untrue images
of god and to to bring ourselves back to
the truth and really it's it's sort of a
journey of um trust
you know learning to trust
that god really is as a theologian for
fuller he said one of his theological
kind of principles or absolutes is god
has to be at least as nice as jesus
i think that's a really good way to put
it that's like this is one of my rules
god has to be at least as nice as jesus
and i think for a lot of us
it's a journey
to get there to like really trust at
that level
and so what i thought might be helpful
tonight is to um hear
someone else's story
about their own kind of journey their
own struggles with their images of like
themselves of others of god and then um
just what kind of the journey that god's
taken them on
so
if you will give a warm welcome from my
friend eric
stennerson y'all give him a hand
the table zone
the table zone eric
thank you
i'm gonna grab my phone
with a timer
because otherwise
who knows how long
all right
eric thank you
thank you yes
um
so let's kind of start um
we'll start towards the beginning
um telling can you maybe just share with
us
um
some of your background you've been
through some really dark times in your
life
um
and
just kind of give us some context um
share some of you know some of what
you've been through to help us you know
get like a snapshot of who's eric my
journey begins
in january of 79 when i was born in
duluth minnesota
um
my birth mother put me up for adoption
and i was known as baby jeremy i was not
known as eric at the time
and i was adopted in late summer of that
year by my parents
however
i never knew my parents married because
they divorced in 1980.
so growing up
i struggled with rejection and the fact
that did i break up the marriage or was
it something else i know
i've been told it's not but you know
and
at the end of sixth grade
i was diagnosed with social anxiety
disorder
and was forced to move to duluth with my
father my mom and i lived in mankato
minnesota so like two and a half hours
south
hour south of minneapolis
and
i continued through high school
moved back to mankato for college
and you know basically lived alone but
however struggled with what became
bipolar
disorder
in full by my twenties
and during that time um
i took try to take my life twice during
my 20s and 30s
i relied heavily on alcohol and abused
my prescription drugs
greatly in order to get the high that i
wanted and to drown out my sorrows
so
but i thought it was all over with when
i met my husband brandon in
uh new year's eve of 17-18
and i thought now i had someone to walk
with in this world and
this is my first relationship um and
it was gonna be great and i put
everything into it that i
had
um however i unfortunately did not know
the difference between a good
relationship and a toxic relationship
because it was my first
and after two and a half years i was
pulled out of that relationship by my
family in august of 2020
and moved here to texas
they lived in roy city and i moved to
greenville
and
however
just didn't quite get back on the path
that i wanted to
and so on november 1st of 2020 i to take
my life for a third time
and i ended up in glen oaks hospital and
you know i vowed when that door shut
behind me five days later and i walked
out that it would never happen again
and so in january of 21 um january is
kind of a new start new year everything
um i met william and who i'm with today
and
that is by far an absolute true
relationship
and
um a loving relationship built on truth
and honesty
and not something that's hidden behind
closed doors so
um here we are and obviously the table
came in october of 21
and so i think
you know there's a lot left out in there
because i'm 43 years old but i think
everybody can understand that it's been
a struggle and unfortunately even with
william it's not a smooth path there
have been some struggles and some bumps
along the way and i think that however
he understands and does not judge just
like god does not judge um neither is he
um
josh i'm hearing feedback does he need
to use my mic
is it okay okay cool um so we've
exchanged a number of emails and um as
eric's kind of shared his story with me
which has been incredibly um encouraging
and um insightful and in one of the
emails you said
um god created me
but i've spent 42 years trying to cover
up and change that
can you kind of unpack that what is that
the covering up the changing that and
then how has that you know kind of
impacted your relationship to god
um
growing up obviously i did not come out
as being gay until i married brandon
because obviously that's kind of
the you know that's there's nothing to
hide behind anymore after that so for
the first 38 years
nobody knew
besides me i mean not my parents
not my friends i mean i'm sure people
had like
you know inklings that you know hey he
doesn't get married to a woman doesn't
have any you know buddy living with him
and so i just i didn't want to be who i
was who god created me to be and so that
just ended up becoming the way it was
going to be and then like i said i
thought i had found that person to walk
with and unfortunately
did not um
but now i have that person so now i can
be who i want to be or who i am
and
being in a place like this
the table
just solidifies that there are people
here on earth that care
love and don't judge as well just like
william does not and god is not so you
know and that really changes who i am
and who i can be myself and like tell
the story because like i'm not
embarrassed by it
because it's truly who i am and there's
nothing to hide behind so yeah
that that kind of ties in with the third
question which is um
you know you've the past few months
you've you've really started to turn
some corners and like
are on a better path whether it's um
you know kind of maturing and deepening
your relationship with william you
mentioned finding the table there's been
kind of a number of things i wondered if
you could kind of be or name what's
what's been helpful what's been kind of
you know setting you free um
and and specifically the what's been
helping you kind of heal some of that
that wound like in yourself between you
and god
uh yeah i think i kind of missed the the
god part in the second question there
but like i felt like i could do it
myself like my 20 30s
sorry um i felt like i didn't need
to have to walk with god on a daily
basis because i mean i had my alcohol i
had my drugs i had
you know i didn't need anybody to be
walking beside me you know i was i was
fine on my own like i mean i'm i'm
strong enough i don't need anything else
and you know if it hurts too bad then i
can just be done and
so now
that god has i think placed
william the table
a steady job
everything in my life that's just been
kind of
my relationship has become stronger
by far and i know that he has done that
for me you know he's he knows what's
coming next and he understands that on
november 1st 2020 he wasn't ready to
call me home yet i was ready but he
wasn't so
here i am and i think that it's changed
exactly who i am and who i want to
become and you know be more like jesus
every day but
i understand that i'm also human and
it's not going to be just always
you know a walk in the park there's
going to be stumbles
but if you have god and
a you know a significant other to lean
on
you you will make it and that's what the
difference is between when you reject
god and then and then you know or invite
him in to be your pillar in life um that
verse luke 13 34
i was not willing at the time
and
now
yes i want to be i want to be uh
included
in the in the
in the god's world and god's creation so
awesome thank you you're welcome thank
you y'all give him a hand
yeah jesse you got me grab this
thank you
isn't god good i love um
eric i appreciate you sharon it takes a
lot of vulnerability to be
to be up here um but i just love hearing
what god's up to
and the way he he it's like god knows
exactly what needs to be healed within
each of us
you know in relationship like to
ourselves to others to him sometimes our
images of him you know but like it's
just such a good work so thank you for
sharing and um i did want to return to
that that phrase um
that jesus uses there
towards the end about
and you were not willing that's the the
end of the passage you were not willing
you can hear almost the heartbreak in it
and what i love in eric's story is what
he named that transition
from that distance and like
i'm gonna figure this out on my own
you know which wasn't working so well
and then this sense of surrender and
openness to god like god okay okay i'm
willing
i'm willing
and not that like like eric mentioned
not that you snap your fingers and
everything is magically solved in my
life and i have no more problems not
that
but but i'm on the path towards
wholeness
i'm taking steps every day towards
towards healing and so as we um just
come to this this linton season
um i guess what i want to encourage us
to be is just willing
let's be let's be willing let's say yes
to god and um see what he has for us
i want to pray for you and then we're
i'm going to transition over to
communion
lord jesus
uh thank you
that you are a good mother
to us
thank you that you offer us
safety stability warmth and comfort
i lift up every person who is
desperately in need of those things
if that's you tonight i want to invite
you to just open up your your palms on
your lap in a posture of just receiving
from god
god may your children receive your love
may our images of you be healed
may we stop projecting our fox-like ways
onto you may every false image of you
planted by the enemy be banished and may
we be filled with your life
in light
in the name of the father
the son
and the holy spirit
amen
so as we come forward for communion
today
it is
it's called a sacrament a a practice
where we are encountering again we are
connecting again with the crucified and
risen one and that's what these these
symbols are about this the um the bread
the wine it's this symbol right of the
body broken the blood poured out for us
it's it's a picture of god's love
so that's what we're doing as we um
participate in this and we practice
what's called an open table meaning if
you're here tonight and you would like
to participate then you are welcome to
even if you're like i don't know if i
have all my theology worked out or what
it's just if you want to participate
you're welcome to and having said that
there's no pressure
if you're not in that place
um
all right i think that's everything so
let me uh let me invite you to the table
with this celtic
invitation
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
in you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord who invites you
and it is his will
that those who want to meet him
should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
do
i asked gary to lead uh this song
tonight it's by one of my favorite
artists josh gorel's
look him up if you haven't um
but i just loved brett's picture and the
message title i just the fox and the hen
i just thought it was so great but that
picture of the mother hen gathering
chicks under her wings it just
immediately took me to this song
and what it's meant to me so um
if you would like to sing along you're
more than welcome but you can also just
sit there and take it in
and
read these words and picture
picture that mother
gathering us together calling us back
home
[Music]
so
back when i was younger
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
joy for me
a place
[Music]
um
along the way
[Music]
oh
will be
[Music]
a place
fun
[Music]
come on
home to me
and i
will hold you in
my arms
[Music]
you
well done you guys that's beautiful
i love that song i love story sunday i
love hearing people's stories eric thank
you so much for coming up here
um earlier i spoke about the five
pillars that the table has been birthed
out of thoughtfulness inclusivity being
eclectic vulnerable and communal
and for someone to come up and share
their story authentically they have to
be vulnerable to a community but you
can't be vulnerable without that
community and you can't truly be safely
vulnerable unless that community is
inclusive but they cannot be inclusive
without profound thoughtfulness
which with all of those things together
is going to build a very eclectic
community and here we are
wow
that's good that's good news y'all
because you're welcome every bit of your
story and who you are truly is welcome
here and eric thank you for for being
courageous enough and brave enough to
not just share your story but to share
the handprints of our god it's beautiful
so if you are looking for a church home
and you want to be a part of our
eclectic patchwork little family here
there are visitor cards on your way out
and you can fill them out we would love
to get to know you help you plug in we
have meetup groups that are super
awesome and other ways that you can
volunteer and share your giftings
and part of
a community like this it has to be
fueled
i said earlier i'm not the financial
person thankfully my husband is
otherwise we would be homeless and that
is the truth
finances come into play
and that literally puts fuel in the tank
right and that is what turns on the
electricity here and as we know gas is
very expensive these days so if you call
the table home i want to encourage you
to figure out ways that you could give
in a monetary way and i know that can
feel icky um but it's it's just the
truth and that's how we keep the lights
on that's how we're able to buy snacks
for the kids so if that
if that is something you're able to do i
encourage you to give generously in that
way to help fuel the
tank that is the table
um i have a beautiful benediction that
my youth pastor shared on facebook the
other day and i really wanted to share
that with you guys tonight i thought it
was a great time for that so
if you'll stand and take a posture of
receiving this blessing for your week
you can stand with open arms closed eyes
whatever just feels right to you
and i would love to to share this with
you
well hot dog i clicked off of it
so that ruined that vibe a little bit
i'm sorry y'all
oh man technology
there's a poem written by my daughter
but i don't think y'all want that one
it's about a tree and a beam y'all
so i'm gonna make this up as i go i'm
not gonna read the one for my youth
pastor i don't know where it went but
we're gonna move with the spirit and
think that maybe i was supposed to share
something differently so when i'm done i
will say peace be with you and you say
and peace be with you and you go on your
way to enjoy and bask in god's goodness
this week
go now in the name of jesus of love
may this week be filled with god's
spirit in truth and goodness may you be
met
by light in your darkness
may you be free to be vulnerable with
people who love you and see you and know
you and help you and guide you by the
power and blood
and love of our jesus
go now in the name of the father the son
and the holy spirit peace be with
you have a great week
[Music]
my arms
is
[Music]
the table
foreign